[Musique]
la séance est ouverte
le compte rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribuée nous
n'avons pas reçu d'observation
est-ce qu'il y en a en séance
je le vois point
le procès verbal est donc adopté sous
les réserves d'usage madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues notre
ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement notre séance
est retransmise en direct sur Public
Sénat et sur notre site internet chacun
sera attentif au respect des uns et des
autres et au respect du temps de parole
je donne immédiatement la parole au
président Claude maluré pour le groupe
Les Indépendants République et
territoires
[Applaudissements]
chaque jour en Ukraine des femmes et des
enfants meurent dans les décombres de
leurs immeubles pulvérisés chaque jour
des soldats tombent parce que manque les
armes pour résister à Wagner et à ses
vagues d'assaut de traine misère envoyés
au massacre
Rammstein il y a quelques jours les
Européens échoués à s'accorder sur la
livraison de Charlot immense déception
qui a cédé la place aujourd'hui même à
un immense soulagement l'accord des
Allemands pressé par l'Europe de l'Est
et du Nord pour livrer les Léopards 2 la
France est désormais devant ses
responsabilités après l'Angleterre la
Pologne les Pays-Bas étaient maintenant
l'Allemagne va-t-elle fournir les
armements capables de changer l'issue de
la guerre les chars et une défense
solaire efficace le président de la
République expliqué que ces armements ne
doivent pas être escalatoires la
décision allemande disciple cet argument
peu pertinent
on ne peut dire aux Ukrainiens qu'on les
soutiendra jusqu'à la victoire finale et
en même temps qu'on ne veut pas
d'escalade parce que par définition la
victoire nécessite une escalade depuis
un an nous laissons à Poutine le
monopole de l'escalade c'est lui qui
fixe les lignes rouges et nous qui
craignons de les franchir alors qu'à
chaque franchissement ces menace se sont
suivies d'aucun effet parce que la
Russie est déjà au maximum de ses
possibilités
quant au chantage à l'armatomique il est
balayé depuis qu'à Samarcande Chi et
maudit ont interdit à un Poutine
pétrifiée de s'en servir il ne peut plus
être l'excuse de nos indécisions au bout
d'un an de guerre nous savons que si le
coup du soutien l'Ukraine est élevé le
coût de ne pas chasser la Russie le
serait bien plus le but de Poutine n'est
pas la seule destruction de l'Ukraine
mais la fin de l'ordre européen
démocratique il ne s'agit plus d'aider
l'Ukraine à sa défendre mais à gagner
madame la Première ministre au-delà des
efforts déjà accomplis le gouvernement
français compte-t-il se joindre à nos
alliés et livrer l'armement lourd
indispensable et quand comptent-ils le
fait chaque jour de retard est un jour
de deuil en Ukraine
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président Claude malgré
cela fait désormais 11 mois que la
Russie a lancé une offensive
injustifiable
inacceptable et brutale sur le
territoire ukrainien 11 mois de
bombardements de morts et de drames
insupportables pour le peuple ukrainien
11 mois que l'Ukraine résiste de manière
héroïque 11 mois que la France lui
apporte un soutien sans faille et comme
la répéter le président de la République
il y a quelques jours nous saurons au
rendez-vous pour aider l'Ukraine jusqu'à
la victoire
depuis bientôt un an l'Ukraine peut
compter sur l'aide militaire
internationale aux côtés de nos
partenaires la France en prend une part
importante nous en sommes un des
premiers contributeurs par la livraison
d'équipements de munitions et la
formation de centaines de soldats
ukrainiens
les matériels que nous livrons font la
différence sur le terrain les Ukrainiens
le soulignent eux-mêmes régulièrement je
pense aux canons César au système de
lance-roquettes unitaire au système de
défense aérienne anti-aérienne crotale
livrées en fin d'année
nous entendons les demandes du président
et du gouvernement ukrainien rien n'est
exclu et nous sommes mobilisés pour les
soutenir dans la durée nous voulons une
action coordonnée avec nos partenaires
internationaux et qui répondent au mieux
aux besoins de l'Ukraine pour assurer sa
défense
pour notre aide militaire nous voulons
respecter trois principes le premier
comme l'a indiqué le président de la
République c'est que notre aide ne doit
pas provoquer d'escalade personne n'y
aurait à gagner et surtout pas l'Ukraine
le second c'est que notre aide doit être
utile et efficace rapidement cela
implique notamment que les forces
ukrainiennes soient en mesure d'être
formées pour utiliser les équipements et
qu'elle puisse en assurer le maintien en
conditions opérationnelles enfin nous ne
devons pas et nous ne voulons pas
affaiblir significativement nos propres
capacités de défense en particulier les
plus critiques
je salue la décision de l'Allemagne sur
le sujet des chars lourds elle permettra
de renforcer les capacités militaires
ukrainiennes en matière de combat blindé
nous avons été particulièrement réactifs
aux demandes de l'Ukraine dans la
matière début janvier le Président de la
République avait initié une dynamique en
annonçant la livraison de Charles léger
amx-10rc la décision allemande renforce
et amplifie le soutien engagé
s'agissant des chars Leclerc nous
poursuivons l'analyse avec le ministre
des Armées la question de l'aide à
l'Ukraine ne se limite pas à tel ou
telle équipement chaque pays dispose de
domaines d'excellence comme la défense
aérienne et l'artillerie pour la France
il est important de bien nous coordonner
enfin j'ajoute que nous avons créé un
fond spécial de soutien de 200 millions
d'euros pour permettre à l'Ukraine
d'acheter le matériel dont elle a le
plus besoin directement auprès de nos
industriels nous sommes également actifs
au niveau européen en prenant toute
notre part à la facilité européenne pour
la paix monsieur le Président maluré
vous le savez j'avais eu l'occasion de
le rappeler lors du débat qu'ils étaient
tenus le 26 octobre ici même notre
soutien à l'Ukraine dépasse le seul
cadre militaire c'est aussi un soutien
humanitaire diplomatique un soutien
grâce au sanctions sans précédent de
l'Union européenne contre la Russie et
un soutien bien sûr à la reconstruction
du pays nous agissons en lien constant
avec nos partenaires européens et nos
alliés nous agissons avec détermination
et Constance nous serons aux côtés de
l'Ukraine jusqu'au bout je peux vous
l'assurer je vous remercie merci madame
la Première ministre
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
Philippe Tabaro pour le groupe les
républicains
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
madame la Première ministre les classes
moyennes ne croient plus et n'écoutent
plus ceux qui les dépossède c'est en ces
termes si jusque le géographe Christophe
Guy lui s'exprimait cette semaine dans
un grand quotidien c'est une
illustration parfaite du ressenti des
Français à la mise en place forcée des
zones affaiblissement mobilité notre
groupe ici au Sénat l'a rappelé il y a
quelques jours lors d'un débat que nous
avons souhaité après la mise en place
chaotique des ZFE du Grand Paris à
Toulouse en passant par Strasbourg ni
sous Toulon nous y avons défendu une
vision équilibrée entre le tout voiture
que nous récupérons et le
jusqu'au-boutisme environnemental qui
voudrait supprimer tous les véhicules
les Français sont-ils informés que 40%
d'entre eux vont devoir dans les
prochaines années amener leur véhicule à
la casse non
l'industrie automobile française et je
dis bien française est-elle prête à
cette transformation vers le tout
électrique non d'après monsieur Tavares
lavitaillement est-il suffisant et
l'impact de la crise énergétique
intégrée au cou et au déploiement des
bornes électriques non la logistique
urbaine est-elle organisée pour nos
petits artisans et leur véhicule
utilitaires non les contrôles sont il
efficaces et efficients non l'offre de
transport en commun enfin est-elle
suffisante ponctuelle et
Eric tel l'ensemble de notre pays non
les ZFE tels que vous les avez mises en
place sont un cafard à homme tout est à
l'envers madame la Première ministre
avez-vous conscience que ces ZF
pourraient être l'étincelle de nouveaux
blocages allez vous mettre fin à cette
marche forcée en sens inverse
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministres de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires monsieur
Béchu monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Tabarro
y a-t-il ici des gens qui pensent que la
question des décès par la pollution
atmosphérique est un sujet secondaire
y a-t-il ici des gens qui contestent la
nécessité de lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique
y a-t-il ici des gens qui considèrent
qu'il faut faire confiance aux élus
locaux quand on met en place des
politiques
et bien mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et monsieur le sénateur
Tabarro vous avez dressé la feuille de
route qui est la nôtre
les zones à faible émission
les zones affaiblission de quoi
s'agit-il d'une invention française non
ça existe dans 14 pays d'Europe la
première a été mise en place en 1996 en
Suède
est-ce que ce dispositif concerne 40%
des automobilistes non il concerne les
agglomérations qui sont en dépassement
de seuil à la suite de la condamnation
par la Cour de justice des Communautés
européennes et par le Conseil d'État le
seul calendrier fixé par l'État je n'ai
aucun doute sur le fait que vous les
rassurer nos concitoyens et faire en
sorte que nous prenions les bonnes
décisions je vous demande juste
d'entendre ce qu'est l'état du droit
l'état du droit c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
calendrier fixé par l'État par rapport
aux véhicules professionnels l'état du
droit c'est que les seuils de
restriction dépendent des dépassements
de la pollution de l'air et qu'à la
minute où nous nous parlons
contrairement à ce que certains disent
c'est nid d'où le pays ni 43
agglomérations qui sont concernés par un
calendrier restrictif le seul calendrier
restrictif fixé par la loi c'est la
sortie des critères 5 si vous êtes en
dépassement de seuil au 1er janvier 2023
critères 4 au 1er janvier 2024 critères
3 au 1er janvier 2025 combien avons-nous
aujourd'hui d'agglomération en
dépassement de seuil on en a moins de 10
les autres elles ont à la fois une
attitude sur la mise en place de mesures
qui permettent d'atteindre les objectifs
puisque c'est une obligation de
résultats pas une obligation de moyens
les critiques que vous avez émises et
dont je me suis réjoui dans cette
émission qui était à la fois plus
nuancée et plus constructive que le
caractère condensé de la question elles
nous ont conduit à mettre en place un
groupe de travail qui associe qui la
métropole de Toulouse est celle de
Strasbourg pour faire en sorte de
proposer des solutions
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre je regrette
votre absence de réponse car c'est vous
qui avez également souhaité comme
ministre des Transports à l'époque ces
ZFE écoutez s'il vous plaît accompagner
nos concitoyens pour que les EDF ne
deviennent pas un sacrifice de plus pour
les Français
la parole est à notre collègue Stéphane
de Milly pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste de la parole merci monsieur le
Président ma question s'adresse
directement à monsieur le ministre du
Travail et indirectement à tous ceux qui
aiment la démocratie
les semaines passent et avec elle
s'approche un projet de loi que personne
ne peut ignorer tant il est médiatisé
tant il déchaîne les passions et tant il
est vrai il impactera la vie future de
nos concitoyens je parle naturellement
de la réforme des retraites certains le
soutiendront sans réserve d'autres
lamanderont pour le rendre plus conforme
à leur conviction d'autres enfin le
combattront fermement les avis divergent
et parfois au sein d'un même groupe
parlementaire mais là n'est pas l'objet
de mon intervention car nous aurons
naturellement l'occasion de revenir sur
ce sujet en février lors des débats
je souhaite plutôt vous parler de la
forme et du climat qui prévaut à ses
futurs échanges la semaine dernière un
important responsable syndicat à la
déclarait je cite qu'il allait s'occuper
des élus qui soutiendraient ce texte en
organisant des coupures de courant les
ciblants directement je trouve ces
propos terriblement scandaleux dans une
démocratie on peut et on doit débattre
les orientations politiques on peut les
soutenir on peut les critiquer on peut
naturellement manifester en revanche
menacer un élu parfois même dans sa vie
privée pour ses prises de position ce
n'est pas tolérable en démocratie c'est
la force des arguments qui comptent et
non les arguments de force la réflexion
l'écoute la sérénité et au final le
jugement ne doivent pas être à la merci
de toute forme d'intimidation de
pression ou de menaces tous les bancs de
cette hémicycle devraient dénoncer de
telles méthodes barbares monsieur le
ministre comment comptez-vous ramener de
la sénité et de la lucidité dans ce
débat budgétaire et sociétal dont tout
le monde gagnerait à ce qu'il soit
beaucoup plus apaisé et beaucoup plus
constructif merci
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion du
merci à Monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs de mi à vrai
dire je partage tout et je crois que
nous sommes nombreux ici sur les bancs
du gouvernement et j'imagine aussi sur
les bancs du Sénat à partager votre
intervention et à partager votre
indignation le débat sur les retraites
est ouvert et c'est effectivement un
débat qui peut être vif un débat qui
peut être agité un débat qui peut être
passionné et je n'ai aucun doute sur le
fait qu'à l'Assemblée nationale comme
ici nous aurons ces débats avec la
première ministre nous souhaitons que
c'est des bases soient les plus
constructives possible les plus ouverts
possibles et nous sommes convaincus que
cette capacité à mener le débat de bonne
qualité jusqu'au bout passe à la fois
par l'affirmation de conviction et
l'affirmation de priorité les notes sont
l'équilibre du système sont la
protection des plus fragiles sont les
mesures les plus justes pour accompagner
la mise en oeuvre de réforme qui doivent
justement nous permettre de revenir à
l'équilibre du système et ainsi de le
pérenniser
dans le cadre de ce débat des mouvements
sociaux sont organisés et les
organisations syndicales sont légitimes
à appeler à des mouvements grèves ou à
des mobilisations elles sont toutes
aussi légitimales faire lorsque les
choses se passent bien comme elles se
sont bien passées dans les cortèges de
la semaine dernière mais dans ce
déballage nous l'avons dit aussi nous ne
souhaitons niblocage que qui serait
pénalisant pour l'ensemble des Français
et nous acceptons aucune menace les
propos que vous avez évoqués ne sont pas
acceptables et un certain nombre des
propos qui ont été tenus des actions qui
ont été envisagées si elles étaient
réalisées relèveraient du délit plus que
de l'action politique ou de l'action
militante et donc nous serons sur cette
ligne là à la fois de clarté
d'affirmations de conviction mais avec
le souci permanent de veiller à ce
qu'aucun acte inacceptable ne puisse
être commis au-delà de votre question
monsieur le sénateur et au-delà de ce
contexte autour de la réforme des
retraites ces menaces proférées à
l'encontre d'élus pour les convictions
qu'ils expriment les positions qu'ils
prennent ne sont évidemment pas
acceptables et renvoie un autre contexte
qui est celui de l'augmentation des
faits de contre les élus et votre
question me permet je le dis sous le
contrôle du ministre de l'intérieur de
souligner qu'aujourd'hui même au Journal
officiel a été publié la loi qui
autorise les associations d'élus et les
assemblées parlementaires à supporter
participe des élus qui ont été victimes
de violence c'est aussi un progrès qu'il
faut souligner pour bien protéger les
élus français
[Applaudissements]
poli pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste
avaient la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre du
Travail évidemment si vous reportez
l'âge légal à 64 ans elles sont un peu
plus pénalisées sur ce point-là elles
sont un peu plus impactés que les hommes
est-ce un syndicaliste un opposant à
votre réforme des retraites qui a tenu
ses propos non cette réalité des
conséquences de votre réforme des
retraites c'est le Ministre Riester qui
le reconnaît vous ne pouvez pas dire que
ce sont des mensonges avec votre réforme
les femmes vont devoir en moyenne
travailler 7 mois de plus pour partir en
retraite contre 5 mois supplémentaires
pour les hommes cette réforme
profondément injuste pour l'ensemble des
salariés il est encore plus pour les
femmes votre réforme va donc aggraver
les inégalités entre les femmes et les
hommes
commencez plutôt par imposer l'égalité
salariale entre les femmes et les pour
dégager 6 milliards de cotisations de
retraite supplémentaire
je pense à ces ouvrières à ces ouvriers
de la marée de Boulogne au travail des
deux heures du matin à celles et ceux
des industries agroalimentaires debout
derrière leur chaîne toute la journée
qui ont commencé leur carrière taux
c'est travailleurs vont cumuler tous les
aspects négatifs de votre réforme je
pense aux aides à domicile aux soignants
aux infirmières aux femmes de ménage aux
caissières que vous applaudissiez durant
la crise sanitaire qui devront
travailler neuf mois supplémentaires
pour les générations de 1972 à l'issue
du conseil de ministre vous avez reconnu
monsieur le ministre que le recul de
l'âge légal serait plus favorable aux
femmes qu'aux hommes dans un premier
temps par vos propres aveux vous
établissez l'injustice de votre texte
nous vous demandons de le retirer et
d'organiser un véritable débat dans le
pays
pour vous répondre la parole est au mini
du travail du plein d'emploi et de
l'insertion monsieur luciole
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice
que vous évoquez et sur la lecture qui
peut être faite parfois ici ou ailleurs
d'ailleurs de l'étude d'impact qui
accompagne le projet de loi de réforme
des retraites peut-être en rappelant
quelques évidences mais qu'il vaut
rappeler dans un tel débat est-ce que là
je d'ouverture des droits sera
différente les hommes et les femmes non
est-ce que la durée de cotisation
requise entre les hommes et les femmes
portera une différence évidemment non
quel est quels sont les conséquences de
la réforme que nous portons il y a
effectivement un rapprochement de l'âge
effectif je ne parle pas de l'âge légal
mais de l'âge effectif de départ entre
les âmes et les femmes mais vous l'avez
certainement noté madame la sénatrice à
la lecture de ce rapport d'évaluation en
2030 les femmes continueront à partir
plus jeune que les hommes à la retraite
et pourquoi elles pourront continuer à
partir plus jeunes que les hommes à la
retraite parce que nous maintenons
l'intégralité de ce que nous appelons
les droits familiaux les quatre
trimestres automatique attribué aux
femmes à l'occasion d'une maternité ces
quatre pour le régime général de pour le
régime de la fonction publique et vous
savez que dans le régime général il y en
a quatre qui peuvent être répartis
librement entre les membres du couple
vous avez aussi vu madame la sénatrice
dans ce même rapport d'évaluation que
les mesures que nous prenons en matière
d'éligibilité à la retraite minimale
garantie comment matière d'éligibilité
au départ anticipé au bénéfice des
carrières longues sont favorables aux
femmes parce que nous intégrons les
trimestres cotisés au titre de
l'assurance vieillesse des parents au
foyer dans les trimestres requis pour
déterminer cette éligibilité tant au
minimum de pension qu'aux dispositif de
départ anticipé pour carrière longue
nous avons veillé ce scrupuleusement
avec un chef de gouvernement dans
chacune des décisions que nous avions à
prendre à protéger les plus fragiles
tous les exemples que vous avez cités
tous les métiers que vous avez évoqué
font partie de ceux qui seront mieux
protégés et mieux accompagnés tant par
les dispositifs de pénibilité que par le
nouveau dispositif de prise en compte
des carrières longues pour ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler avant 18 ans je
suis sûr dans le débat nous trouverons
des convergences sur ces points là
monsieur le ministre vous avez refusé
l'étude d'impact vous êtes incapable
aujourd'hui de nous donner le nombre de
françaises qui de français d'ailleurs
qui bénéficierait des 1200 euros bruts
monsieur le ministre il y a 10 ans vous
étiez le grand défenseur de la retraite
à 60 ans vous avez changé évidemment
d'avis entre deux mais ce n'est pas
étonnant de votre part
la parole est de notre collègue Ludovic
et pour le conte du rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et indépendants
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur Sébastien Lecornu ministre des
Armées monsieur le ministre le 20
janvier dernier lors de la présentation
de CV aux armées à Mont-de-Marsan le
président de la République a indiqué que
la France a loué à ses armées un budget
davantage conséquent sur la période
2024-2030
la prochaine loi de programmation
militaire articulée autour de quatre
pivots principaux à savoir notre cœur de
souveraineté la haute intensité la
protection de nos intérêts et nos
partenariats renouvelés attribuera 413
milliards d'euros aux forces armées soit
118 milliards de plus que la loi de
programmation militaire actuelle même
s'il convient de tenir compte d'un
présent contexte inflationniste le
président de la République a rappelé le
contexte particulier de menaces dans
lequel nous sommes et l'émergence des
formes de conflictualité nouvelles cet
effort conséquent rassure non seulement
notre communauté militaire nous
décideurs et nos élus mais également
notre communauté et qu'il traduit de
faire de du président de la France un
président plus souverain plus
entreprenant et plus agile
c'était fort ne permettra
indubitablement d'avoir une guerre
d'avance notre Parlement y veillera
notre souveraineté passera non seulement
par leur renfort de notre dissuasion par
nos postures permanentes mais aussi par
la résilience nationale il est vrai
qu'il nous faut agir partout plus vite
et plus fort
cette dernière LPM placée sous le signe
de la transformation prendra le relais
de l'ancienne qui avait déjà été marqué
par un effort signé fixatif en matière
de réparation cela demandera rassurément
une forme d'agilité car comme vous le
savez de nombreuses infrastructures
dépendent totalement du matériel qu'elle
supporte je pense notamment au base
aérienne exclusivement équipé de
d'avions de type mirage ou
d'établissement de type psaïe qui
maintiennent aujourd'hui des
hélicoptères d'anciennes génération de
type gazelle ou type Puma et qui peine à
se projeter dans l'avenir monsieur le
ministre dans un contexte où la
souveraineté est redevenu un axe de
réflexion important de tout premier plan
comment pensez-vous concilier cette
politique forte de transformation avec
le développement de nos infrastructures
militaires et de notre industrie de
défense dans nos territoires monsieur le
ministre comment souhaitez-vous associer
les territoires à cet effort inédit sans
égal mesures depuis la présidence du
général de Gaulle
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre des Armées monsieur Sébastien
Lecornu merci monsieur le Président du
Sénat mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur bon le ministère
des armées est un grand ministère
territorial et pour cause il est
représenté et présent dans les
différents territoires et donc de fait
en 2 minutes lister les impacts de
l'autre programmation militaire et très
difficile je vais essayer de donner
quelques lignes bon un déjà la
réparation continue et c'est
particulièrement vrai sur les
infrastructures on le sait très bien
beaucoup de régiment beaucoup de base
navale beaucoup de bases aériennes sont
encore dans un état absolument
déplorable fruits de décision qui
parfois ont été prises il y a très
longtemps et sur lequel la réparation
prendra du temps il faut donc le dire
avec humilité la deuxième des choses la
réparation continue sur les services de
soutien c'est particulièrement vrai pour
le commissariat c'est vrai pour le
service de santé des armées je sais que
c'est un sujet qui est suivi par les
membres de la commission de la défense
et des forces armées du Sénat et là on
le voit bien c'est soutiens aussi ont
été abîmés la réparation prendra du
temps dans des contextes qui sont
difficiles alors c'est quand on parle de
transformation il va sans dire que
transformation vont être moins
spectaculaires sur les territoires que
dans le passé et pour cause déjà
puisqu'on ne ferme aucun régiment aucune
base aérienne aucun laboratoire de la
DGA donc par définition c'est une
transformation interne à bas bruit c'est
vrai sur le terrain technologique vous
l'avez visitez le Scorpion rafale il y a
des sauts technologiques qui sont
importants et qui vont forcément
transformer la vie des unités c'est vrai
également sur les métiers nouveaux le
cyber le spatial les fonds sous-marins
dans l'occasion d'y revenir ici même
c'est vrai également aussi la
transformation RH du ministère puisque
vous aurez forcément un pivot en matière
de ressources humaines veillez soit aux
réserves avec un nouveau ratio de
réserviste aura un impact important pour
les régiments de l'armée terre et dans
le grand est singulièrement on sera
amené à y revenir dans les temps qui
viendront c'est vrai aussi pour le
pyramidage entre les sous-officiers et
la troupe puisque les fonctions
nouvelles qui amènent se saut de
technologie demande aussi évidemment
beaucoup plus de savoir-faire en tout
cas de monter en puissance de
compétences je reviendrai vers vous sur
ces sujets on peut aussi citer en 10
secondes
un impact en matière d'emploi pour la
BITD aux quatre coins de l'hexagone une
feuille de route pour l'outre-mer que le
Président de la République voudra
détailler lui-même sur les impacts de
notre programmation militaire pour nos
territoires
ultramarins et la relation avec les
collectivités territoriales sur lequel
je veux qu'on arrive à systématiser les
choses notamment pour le plan famille
merci Monsieur merci
je vais donner la parole maintenant à la
présidente Laurence Rossignol pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
République
[Applaudissements]
du sexisme au niveau dans notre société
ce qui explique d'ailleurs que la
condition des femmes reste soumise aux
inégalités et aux violences c'était
consistème sexiste impose aux femmes de
toute jour de voir s'adapter esquiver
résister c'est un effort constant et
puisqu'on parle d'effort le même jour
avec un sens du timing étonnant le
ministre Riester dans un moment de
franchise merveilleux a dit en effet
cette réforme va demander aux femmes un
effort supplémentaire alors je dis
clairement pour ce qui est des femmes
les efforts c'est non on en fait déjà
assez comme ça tout le temps
alors
vous répétez en boucle que la pension
minimum va passer maintenant à 1200
euros mais les conditions d'accès à
cette pension celle d'une carrière
complète sont tellement drastiques que
justement elles vont éviter les femmes
les femmes justement ont des carrières
arrachées elles ne pourront pas profiter
de cette de cette pension à 1200 euros
dont vous nous parlez par ailleurs il y
a une chose qui est sûr c'est qu'elles
vont devoir travailler plus longtemps et
non seulement plus longtemps mais plus
longtemps que les hommes qui vont devoir
travailler plus longtemps puisque selon
les études des experts ce sera le double
d'un allongement de la durée du travail
pour les femmes appartenaient à partir
de 1972 c'est un peu compliqué mais ça
prouve quand même que votre réforme
accroît les inégalités entre les femmes
et les hommes comme toutes les réformes
qui sont supposées neutres et qui en
réalité accroissent toujours les
inégalités alors puisqu'on parle
d'efforts les femmes en font beaucoup je
l'ai déjà dit madame la Première
ministre vous vous pouvez vous êtes la
femme qui peut faire un bel effort en
renonçant à cette retraite injuste pour
les femmes
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre du Travail il pleine emploi de
l'insertion merci monsieur le président
madame la Présidente Rossignol je me
reviens pas sur les éléments que j'ai
donné en réponse à madame la sénatrice
du groupe communisme précédemment
simplement vous dire un certain nombre
de choses la réforme que nous menons est
une réforme qui porte des protections
pour les fins vous avez du mal à
l'entendre je crois ou à le concevoir
mais au-delà des dispositions que nous
prenons il y en a une que je n'ai pas
rappelé qui est que nous avons veillé
est-ce que l'âge de suppression de la
décote soit maintenu à 67 ans l'âge de
suppression de décote d'aujourd'hui
parce que 20% des femmes ont une
carrière incomplète et que ce sont
l'essentiel des de celles et ceux qui
vont jusqu'à 70 ans qui justement sont
des fans nous veillons avec la retraite
minimum à ce que justement les femmes
qui ont les carrières les plus fragiles
des carrières hachées que vous avez
décrites les carrières avec les revenus
les plus bas soit bénéficiaires la
retraite minimum que nous mettons en
place va permettre à 200 000 nouveaux
retraités par an c'est-à-dire un départ
à la retraite sur 4
bénéficier d'une pension meilleure avec
la réforme que sans la réforme et les
deux tiers se bénéficiaires sont des
femmes parce que justement et là je vous
rejoins les femmes sont les plus
exposées à la précarité et aux carrières
agées le temps me manque pour décrire
les mécanismes mais le fait que nous
ayons fait le choix de revaloriser le
minimum contributif majoré qui est
accessible dès 120 trimestres cotisés le
fait que nous ayons fait le choix de
revalorer le minimum le revaloriser le
minimum contributif de base accessible à
toutes celles et ceux qui ont travaillé
permet justement de protéger les plus
fragiles nous n'avons pas les mêmes
priorités madame la sénatrice vous
parlez de carrière complète nous pas
vous parler de carrière complète nous
nous adressons justement à celles qui
n'ont pas des carrières complètes et qui
bénéficieront des revalorisations et des
systèmes de protection que nous mettons
en place c'est ça notre priorité
protéger les plus fragiles protéger
celles et ceux qui sont exposés à la
précarité et aux difficultés de carrière
c'est avec cette loi que nous allons
faire et c'est avec ces dispositions que
nous allons y arriver je termine par un
point pour soutenir un point d'accord
avec votre question vous avez cité le
rapport le conseil et l'égalité et ce
conseil montre aussi que notre système
de retraite qu'on accuse parfois tous
les mots est aussi le réceptacle d'une
vie d'inégalité travaillons sur ces
inégalités faisant en sorte de les
résorber et les retraites seront
beaucoup plus justes tout le monde en
train satisfait merci
la parole est à notre collègue Henri
Cabanel pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre l'agriculture de la
souveraineté alimentaire la viticulture
et la filière qui a subi le plus
d'alerte successifs lundi le président
de la Chambre d'agriculture de l'Hérault
a pris l'initiative d'une réunion en
urgence pour alerter les parlementaires
de cette crise sans précédent
2019 taxe Trump 2020 2021 covid 2021
énorme gel de la grêle de la sécheresse
2022 guerre en Ukraine avec ses
conséquences économiques au-delà du
drame humain pénurie de bouteilles
augmentation du prix du verre des
engrais du carton etc et l'inflation qui
est un impact direct sur la consommation
par exemple - 15 % sur les vins rouges
un chiffre très inquiétant car la
viticulture française est un secteur qui
réalise depuis de 14 milliards d'euros
d'excellents commerciales le Bordelais a
récemment manifesté sa colère car le
désespoir gagne ses vignerons nous
venons avec le groupe vignetin avant la
séance reçue un collectif de
viticulteurs bordelais abattu désespéré
mais combatif
lundi le président des Gias de l'Hérault
consterné à souligner la catastrophe du
contexte pour les jeunes installés
depuis deux trois ans qui et qui
accumule les galères et les crises alors
que leur projet diticoles est
parfaitement sain
si une remise en question structurée est
nécessaire et les organismes
professionnels ça me parle que
proposez-vous monsieur le ministre pour
aider cette filière allez-vous se tenir
la demande de d'étalement de
remboursement des PGE de 6 à 10 ans
allez-vous répondre à la demande de
distillation adossée à la recherche
temporaire où nous définitifs à l'aide
au stockage allez vous soutenir la
création d'un plan de relance
commerciale
pour répondre la parole est ministre de
l'Agriculture de la souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur féno
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Cabanel merci de cette question
vous avez raison la situation dans la
filière
vinicole et grave elle a commencé où les
premières allêtes ont été faites
d'ailleurs votre collègue la sénatrice
de l'athme avait alerté 17 été elle a
commencé en particulier dans le
Bordelais
c'est le cumul comme vous l'avez dit de
différentes crises sur lesquelles
d'abord je tiens à le dire le
gouvernement et vous le savez est
beaucoup intervenu puisque sur le gel il
a couvert à hauteur d'un milliard
d'euros la perte qu'il est intervenu
aussi sur d'autres dispositifs pour
accompagner la filière sociale vous avez
raison ça ne suffit pas parce que nous
sommes dans une crise à la fois
conjoncturelle et une crise structurelle
crise conjoncturelle liée à
l'augmentation particulière des matières
sèches et l'augmente et poussée par
l'inflation des prix du carburant et des
prix pardon des matières énergétiques en
particulier et donc on a travaillé sur
un plan d'allongement des charges et qui
concerne aussi les viticulteurs nous
devons travailler et nous sommes en
train de travailler avec mes services
puisqu'on a sur la table 3 ou 4
dispositifs le premier c'est la
poursuite du PGE nous y travaillons avec
le ministère de l'économie et des
finances pour voir dans quelles
conditions ça peut se faire le deuxième
élément c'est l'aide au stockage ou à la
distillation
qui peut être un élément complémentaire
pour régler le trop sur les choses et
puis le troisième élément qui est un
élément plus structurel qui est
l'arrachage pensant particuliers à ce
qui se passe dans le Bordelais pour
réguler une surproduction qui est
surproduction structurelle pour le coup
et puis évidemment nous devons
travailler sur ce que vous avez dit
c'est à dire la capacité qu'à cette
filière a aussi ou s'ouvrir des
perspectives à l'export il y a une
évolution des modes de consommation il
faut qu'on puisse en tenir compte de
l'ensemble de ses dispositifs qu'on est
en train d'expertiser c'est compliqué
pour chacun d'entre eux à la fois pour
des raisons budgétaires pour le PGE
c'est compliqué aussi pour d'autres
raisons donc on a besoin de regarder
précisément ce qu'on peut faire et on
dirait en vérité ce qu'on peut faire
est-ce qu'on peut pas faire aux filières
je les réunirai au tout début du mois de
février pour regarder l'ensemble des
dispositifs et apporter des premières
réponses concrètes reconnaissons aussi
qu'un certain nombre de dispositifs qui
relèvent du règlement communautaire je
pense en particulier à l'arrachage qui
nécessite du temps donc j'ai besoin avec
vous et avec eux de construire des
mesures d'urgence et puis des mesures
qui leur donnent des perspectives sur le
moyen long terme parce que c'est bien
c'est deux tensions qu'il faut essayer
de de conjurer et aussi en tout cas en
particulier pour les jeunes mais pas
seulement de leur donner des pers
jusqu'à ce que la crise est en effet
assez grave
merci monsieur le ministre de ces
réponses vous savez nous sommes nombreux
sur tous ces bancs à vouloir que la
France reste la référence mondiale au
niveau du vin vous l'avez dit la
situation est grave mais et certainement
les pas désespérés aussi je vous propose
donc de vous appuyer surtout les
parlementaires au-delà de votre majorité
qui connaissent parfaitement leur
territoire parce que l'union fait la
force et je crois que la viticulture a
besoin de ça merci merci la parole est à
notre collègue Guy ménaroche pour le
groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la Justice et
concerne les quartiers disciplinaires
ces lieux ne sont pas perçus par hasard
comme des lieux de moindre droit les
conditions de vie sont plus dures quand
des tensions générales les garanties
comme la superficie médiévale des
cellules la possibilité de promenade la
possibilité de contact avec l'extérieur
par les droits de visite ou par le
téléphone semble parfois oublier l'État
français ne brille pas par l'état de ses
prisons et par les conditions de
détention les quartiers disciplinaires
sur le reflet exacerbé de ces problèmes
et le Comité pour la protection contre
la torture du Conseil de l'Europe alors
de sa visite établit de nouveaux des
constats qui ne nous font pas odeur
actuellement la durée maximale y est de
30 jours le comité a recommandé à
nouveau aux autorités françaises de
prendre les mesures législatives
nécessaires pour assurer que le
placement à l'isolement disciplinaire de
dépasse pas 14 jours pour une infraction
donnée commise par un adulte et soit de
préférence d'une durée inférieure ces
recommandations nous paraissent
nécessaires et le début d'une réelle
prise en compte des difficultés au sein
des quartiers disciplinaires et je me
dois d'évoquer les doutes portés sur les
mauvais traitements et le manque de
transparence de traçabilité qui est
hélas fait croître les doutes et les
suspicions entre autres sur les
circonstances de certains événements et
certains suicides suicides qui semble
aussi plus important dans ces lieux où
les privations peuvent créer des
conditions favorables au passage à
l'acte le CPT regrette aussi que le
recours à la force qui peut parfois
parfois se justifier ne soit pas
systématiquement répertorié et quand il
est que les données de permettent pas de
démontrer en quoi celui-ci s'avère
strictement nécessaire et appliqué dans
le respect du principe de
proportionnalité aussi je souhaiterais
savoir si le ministère contre ordre
disponible les chiffres liés au quartier
disciplinaire nombre de séjour durée
durée moyenne nombre de suicide afin de
permettre d'état des lieux de la
situation et pour enclencher une réforme
des quartiers disciplinaire je
souhaiterais aussi coder votre avis sur
les possibilités d'aménager les
restrictions aux conséquences trop
importantes sur les détenus des
quartiers disciplinaires
pour vous répondre la parole est au
garde des souvenirs de la justice
Monsieur Eric Dupont-Moretti merci
monsieur le Président du Sénat mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs ce sénateur
benaroche je vous communiquerai très
volontiers les chiffres je vais demander
à la direction de l'administration
pénitentiaire de me les communiquer dès
que je les ai jolie communique mais ne
laissons pas entendre s'il vous plaît
que le quartier disciplinaire autrement
appelé mitard serait le lieu de
l'arbitraire absolu je rappelle que des
tenues quand il est envoyé au mitard
comparé devant une commission composée
du directeur de l'établissement
pénitentiaire d'un assesseur qui vient
de la société civile qu'il peut être
défendu par un avocat
naturellement nous avons évoqué ici au
Sénat c'est le président François Noël
buffet qui est à l'initiative de cette
proposition de loin sur les conditions
indignes les conditions indignes elles
touchent la détention ordinaire comme
naturellement les quartiers
disciplinaires et nous y sommes
particulièrement sensibles je veux à ce
titre vous indiquer que nous avons
consacré plus de 130 millions d'euros
par an pour la rénovation mais les
choses ne se font pas en un claquement
de doigts j'ai déjà eu hélas l'honneur
et le déplaisir en même temps de le dire
la justice c'est un abandon
de trois décennies sur le plan humain
sur le plan budgétaire et sur le plan
politique par ailleurs s'agissant des
suicides évidemment que le quartier
disciplinaire peut être un facteur
favorisant si j'ose dire nous y sommes
très attentifs le personnel
pénitentiaire
prend un certain nombre de dispositions
nous faisons venir des médecins
également pour que on s'occupe davantage
des détenus tout cela est en cohérence
parce que vous avez bien compris que le
suicide d'un détenu c'est un échec je
vous ouvre la porte de la Chancellerie
je vous communique les chiffres monsieur
le sénateur très prochainement et nous
réfléchirons ensemble ce que vous avez
évoqué mais je le dis ça n'est pas pour
le moment à l'ordre du jour
vous avez quelques secondes
merci monsieur le ministre je voulais
juste signaler que quelques fois
certains processus administratifs
peuvent créer des problèmes par exemple
le passage en quartier disciplinaire de
détenus parce qu'il possède des
portables qui ne sont pas ceux qui sont
bien disposition par administration et
on sait que les contrats les marchés
d'état de l'administration faut que ces
portables-là leur coûts de communication
coûtent 10 fois plus cher que net
n'importe lequel d'entre nous le coût
d'une communication normale donc il y a
aussi un certain nombre de mesures à
prendre y compris dans les marchés qui
sont passés aujourd'hui par l'État
albinister pour ces matériels
la parole est à notre collègue lors
d'Archos pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion monsieur le ministre le
gouvernement vient de présenter sa
réforme des retraites et le moins que
l'on puisse dire et que les femmes
pourraient être les grandes perdantes
des mesures à venir l'étude d'impact le
démontre clairement elles devront
travailler en moyenne 7 mois de plus
alors que les hommes ne seront astreints
à 5 mois supplémentaires en outre de
nombreuses femmes pouvaient partir dès
62 ans à taux plein grâce au trimestre à
qui lors de la naissance de leurs
enfants avec votre réforme elles devront
travailler deux ans de plus pour
atteindre le nouvel âge légal de 64 ans
et perdront le bénéfice de cette
bonification vous aurez beau jeu de
souligner qu'en travaillant plus
longtemps et bénéficieront d'une
retraite de revaloriser vous ne
manquerez pas de rappeler également
quels seront les premières bénéficiaires
de la hausse au minimum de la pension du
minimum de pension mais de quelle
retraite parlons-nous vous n'ignorez pas
que la retraite des femmes et de %
inférieur à celle des hommes parce
qu'elles sont les premières victimes des
inégalités salariales vous ne pouvez
ignorer non plus qu'elles ont des
carrières fréquemment interrompues par
des maternités qui réduisent la durée de
cotisation et font d'elle les plus
touchées par la décote dans ces
conditions il est indispensable de
compenser les forces supplémentaires
demandées aux femmes de mieux en prendre
en compte leur maternité car une réforme
des retraites par répartition ne peut se
désintéresser de la politique familiale
et d'avancer l'âge de la décote à ce
stade du projet loi et avant les
discussions parlementaires ces mesures
nous paraissent plus équitables que
l'allongement de la durée de vie active
pour améliorer le taux de pension
êtes-vous prêt monsieur le ministre à
corriger ces injustices qui concernent
les femmes et que notre groupe a déjà
pointé à plusieurs reprises sur un sujet
aussi grave nous aurons à cœur de
trouver dans la majorité sénatoriale
comme un autre habitude une solution de
compromis acceptable par tous je vous
remercie pour votre réponse
monsieur le ministre du Travail le
emploi de l'insertion je vous donne la
parole merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice darkos d'abord vous
avez raison sur un point en particulier
qui est je crois fondamental dans ces
débat sur les retraites et sur les
inégalités de niveau de retraite entre
les femmes et les hommes aujourd'hui 50%
des femmes retraitées ont une retraite
inférieure à 1000 euros brut parce que
c'est la conséquence l'effet miroir
d'une inégalité face au travail d'une
égalité face au salaire et ce mouvement
sociologique que nous connaissons
d'augmentation du taux d'activités
d'augmentation du taux d'emploi des
femmes corrige petit à petit et bien
trop lentement cette inégalité qui est
simplement le fruit des inégalités
professionnelles et de carrière c'est là
peut-être la priorité rétablir l'égalité
professionnelle pour que n'ayons pas au
moment des départs à la retraite à
imaginer à penser des systèmes de
retraite qui soit en réalité des
systèmes qui viennent corriger des
inégalités accumulées tout au long de la
vie nous avons dans le projet qu'elle
notre un effort qui est demandé à tous
les salariés femmes et hommes quelle que
soit leur cadre d'emploi quel que soit
leur campemploi privé public régime
nous savons que le départ effectif l'âge
de départ effectif des femmes va se
rapprocher de celui des hommes même si
je les dis tout à l'heure l'âge moyen de
départ des femmes restera inférieur à
celui des hommes nous avons voulu
apporter des corrections et des
protections j'ai évoqué la question de
la retraite minimum vous l'avez fait
vous-même je pourrais évoquer par
exemple ou révoquer le fait que nous
allons intégrer dans les trimestres
prises en compte les trimestres cotisés
au titre de l'assurance vieillesse pour
les parents au foyer cela concerne un
million 900 000 femmes notamment parmi
les moins favorisés tant pour les
éligibilité au minimum de pension que
pour les éligibilité au départ anticipé
pour carrière longue nous avons
certainement encore du travail à faire
autour de la question des aidants nous
allons créer cette assurance vieillesse
pour les aidants ce sont souvent des
femmes nous avons aussi un travail à
faire pour harmoniser les droits comment
expliquer qu'aujourd'hui une maternité
soit génératrice si je puis dire de 4
trimestres de manière automatique au
titre du régime général et de deux au
titre de la fonction publique nous avons
d'ores et déjà demandé avec madame la
Première ministre au Conseil
d'orientation des retraites d'ouvrir un
chantier sur ce sujet là j'espère que
les débats parlementaires nous permettra
d'avancer sur cette question des droits
familiaux sur cette question de la
parentalité de la maternité mais aussi
sur les questions de réversion le texte
tel qu'il sera adopté je l'espère par
l'Assemblée nationale nous permettra
certainement de construire des consensus
merci Monsieur ministre j'entends ce que
vous dites et en effet
vous allez déjà revaloriser en effet les
plus les plus retraite mais on voudrait
pouvoir également parler au nom de
toutes ces femmes qui travaillent depuis
longtemps qui ont des beaux Jobs et qui
ont eu des moments aussi formidables de
d'arrêt avec avec leurs congés maternité
donc de toutes les secteurs d'activités
je parle aussi bien évidemment des des
femmes dans le milieu de l'agriculture
la délégation a fait déjà beaucoup dans
d'autres dans plein de secteurs et donc
je vous inviterai avec la secrétaire de
Madame Rome a pouvoir regarder nos
rapports et nos projets pour pouvoir
également construire la fin de ce projet
de loi sur les retraites tous ensemble
la parole est à notre collègue Michel
meunier pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
[Applaudissements]
que le président du Sénat madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues il y a un
an quasiment jour pour jour paressait
les fossoyeur le livre de Victor
Castanet sur le système ORPEA chacun a
salué l'enquête minutieuse et le prix
Albert Londres est bien mérité mais
maintenant
les dysfonctionnements sont connus les
sanctions sont prononcées les EHPAD
lucratifs doivent être mieux encadrés
puisqu'il prospère du fruit des
cotisations et de la solidarité
nationale le Sénat ici à proposer de
renforcer le contrôle des ehpads et si
nous avons modifié ce cadre législatif
sur le terrain les moyens humains
restent lacunaire distant sur pièce
comptable bien loin de nos
recommandations pour des inspections
contrôles coordonnées dès lors les
questions subsistent monsieur le
ministre de l'autonomie entendez-vous
nos concitoyennes et nos concitoyens qui
espèrent plus d'attention et de soins
pour leur aînés
entendez-vous les familles révoltées à
juste titre des maltraitances parfois
infligées à leurs proches entendez-vous
l'alerte de la Défenseur des droits et
surtout monsieur le ministre prenez-vous
la mesure de l'attente des soignantes et
des soignants qui disent nous devons
être plus nombreuses pour mieux
travailler pour cesser de nous un
éreinter et pour éviter d'être inapte à
l'heure de la retraite
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste des solidarités de
l'autonomie et des personnes handicapées
monsieur Jean-Christophe combe
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices mais c'est le sénateur madame
la sénatrice Michel meunier vous l'avez
rappelé il y a un an sortait l'enquête
approfondie de Victor Castanet qui a
produit une onde de choc dans notre
société à l'époque j'étais moi-même
gestionnaire dans une association
gestionnaire d'établissements
médico-sociaux et j'ai été profondément
choquée par l'ensemble de ces
révélations depuis lors je n'ai eu de
cesse que de m'engager pour ramener la
confiance de nos concitoyens dans les
EHPAD et protéger les personnes âgées on
rôle aujourd'hui en tant que ministre
des Solidarités de l'autonomie et des
personnes handicapées c'est de faire en
sorte de poser un cadre de réguler un
secteur et de faire en sorte que ce
cadre soit respecté et je le dis de
façon très claire et de façon très ferme
tous ceux qui aujourd'hui pensent
pouvoir se décharger de leur
responsabilité en attaquant commettent
une double faute la première c'est qu'il
manque aux Français c'est que ils ne
disent pas la vérité et la seconde c'est
qu'à l'époque ils n'ont pas été à la
hauteur et qu'ils ne le sont toujours
pas aujourd'hui malheureusement et la
vérité c'est que l'état des les premiers
jours de ses révélations agit de façon
extrêmement puissante en lançant une
vague de contrôle inédite avant tous les
20 ans ces établissements étaient
contrôlés on va les contrôler maintenant
tous les deux ans 1400 établissements
sur les 7500 ont d'ores et déjà été
contrôlés 700 on fait l'objet
d'inspection contrôle grâce au
recrutement de 120 contrôleur
supplémentaires dans les ARS et je salue
le travail approfondi des ARS pour faire
en sorte que ça ne se reproduise pas le
deuxième élément que je voulais soulever
c'est celui du tabou de la maltraitance
contre les personnes adultes vulnérables
il faut lever cet about libérer la
parole je lancerai dans quelques jours
une plateforme de recueil des
signalements pour pouvoir libérer cette
la parole et des états généraux de la
maltraitance auront lieu dans quelques
semaines et qui réuniront l'ensemble des
acteurs police justice famille personne
concernées et puis enfin c'est le
travail que nous me conduisons pour
transformer le secteur 9 milliards
d'euros en 50 seront investis pour
transformer l'offre médico-sociale
merci
madame
si vous aussi de ce modèle marchand qui
ne peut rémunérer des actionnaires que
s'il s'occupe mal des personnes âgées si
c'est le cas vous trouverez sur nos
bancs ici au Sénat des soutiens pour y
mettre fin et ça passera par l'examen
d'une loi grand âge elle consacrera
cette loi démolias humains renforcée et
des financements pérennes il faut
fléchir une partie de la richesse créée
dans notre pays vers la prise en charge
des personnes en perte de tonomie mais
les Françaises et les Français ne
souhaitent pas que cet effort consolide
la cotisation la cotation pardon
boursière des grands groupes d'EHPAD et
viennent dans les poches du CAC 40
[Applaudissements]
la parole de notre collègue Valérie
Boyer pour le groupe les républicains
monsieur le ministre j'associe mon
collègue Laurent saumon à ma question il
y a trois mois alors que le
vice-président du Sénat Roger carochi
vous interrogez sur le rapatriement des
femmes et des enfants de djihadistes
vous avez répondu je vous cite en
réalité notre doctrine n'a pas changé
ironie ou mépris en effet depuis 2009
c'était le cas par cas pour les enfants
dans une logique purement humanitaire et
la tolérance zéro pour les femmes et je
ne veux employer le terme rapatriement
car il s'agit de revenante nous
apprenons par la presse que 15 femmes et
32 enfants sont revenus sans compter des
31 femmes et les 67 enfants l'année
dernière
assumez-vous ce changement de troctrine
c'est-à-dire l'abandon du cas par cas et
ses retours massifs comment assurez-vous
la prise en charge de ces enfants par
les services de l'ASEE déjà au bord de
l'asphyxie comme l'enfermement de ces
femmes dans nos prisons déjà saturés et
qui sont considérés parfois comme des
héroïnes comment pouvez-vous garantir la
sécurité des Français face à ces
personnes qui haïssent toujours la
France
vous répondre la parole
est au garde des sceaux ministres de la
Justice monsieur Dupont-Moretti monsieur
le Président du Sénat mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs madame la sénatrice Boyer
ni ironie ni prix votre champ lexical
aurait peut-être pu vous permettre
d'envisager d'autres choses nous n'avons
pas changé la position du gouvernement
est extrêmement claire et elle est
précise ceux qui ont choisi daesh
doivent être jugés au plus près des
lieux où ils ont commis leur crime mais
mais ça n'est pas un petit mais il y a
des enfants madame la sénatrice oui qui
n'ont rien choisi et qui doivent être
traités avec humanité et vigilance
humanité parce que ce sont des enfants
et j'ajoute des enfants français ne vous
en déplaisent
et vigilance parce que ils sont
susceptiblement
susceptiblement possiblement d'être
traumatisé à vie avec toutes les
séquelles que cela peut-ongendrer alors
non nous n'avons pas changé nous
rapatrions à la demande chaque fois que
cela est possible des femmes qui le
demandent avec des enfants en ayant
naturellement à l'esprit la sécurité de
nos forces de l'ordre qui se trouvent
sur place parce que nous ne maîtrisons
pas tout les femmes ont toutes fait
l'objet d'une judiciarisation quand aux
enfants ils sont placés parfois auprès
de leurs grands-parents qui sont des
gens parfaitement intégrés parfaitement
honnêtes et je le redis parfaitement
français madame la sénatrice voilà les
enfants font l'objet d'un suivi
sanitaire d'un suivi médical d'un suivi
psychologique fermeté pour les femmes
humanité vigilance pour les enfants on
pourrait tomber d'accord là-dessus un
élite de l'ironie ni du mépris
madame Boyer
monsieur le ministre
humanité vous n'en avez pas le monopole
et personne ici ne peut nier que nous
aussi nous souhaitons traiter les
enfants en revanche en revanche la
doctrine du cas par cas avait été adopté
par vos prétesseurs Monsieur Le Drian et
Madame beloubet qu'en est-il aujourd'hui
pourquoi changer vous de doctrine en
openant désormais pour des migrations
mortifères massives le président Macron
le président Macron lui-même considérait
que ses retours étaient trop dangereux
pour la sécurité des Français qu'en
est-il aujourd'hui des personnes qui
restent combien sont-elles vous injecter
dans la population française des
djihadistes alors que notre pays est
déjà gangrené par le salafisme
n'oublions pas n'oublions pas que la
France avec 1400 individus et le premier
pays européen et le deuxième pays au
monde à avoir fourni des terroristes à
l'état islamiste
avec des femmes qui se sont engagées
pour aller combattre en Syrie et en Irak
contre la France aujourd'hui avons-nous
les moyens d'une telle politique
de l'Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
personne ne peut ignorer ce fléau
l'usage détourné du protoxyde d'azote
explose en France si tu as la troisième
place des produits psychoactifs les plus
utilisés notamment chez les jeunes
adultes son caractère addictif est
aujourd'hui scientifiquement avérées le
nombre de cas évalués par les réseaux
des centres de pharmacovigilance qui
sont les cas les plus sévères et qui
donnent souvent lui à une
hospitalisation a été multipliée par 10
en 3 ans et ce n'est que la face émergée
de l'iceberg jour après jour les
autorités sanitaires découvrent de
nouvelles complications suite à cette
consommation massive et inédite ces cas
bien plus grave que d'autres produits
qualifiés comme stupéfiants ces cas
révèle des symptômes psychiatriques
anxiétés psychose ou autre troubles du
comportement mais aussi des conséquences
lourdes sur la sensibilité la motricité
avec des séquelles parfois irréversibles
pouvant aller jusqu'à une sclérose
combinée de la moelle épinière face à ce
fléau à cette
face à ce phénomène toujours croissant
et interpellé par les acteurs de terrain
professionnels de santé magistrat élu
démunies j'ai déposé un second texte
visant à délictualiser la consommation
de protoxyde d'azote et à poursuivre les
personnes qui conduisent sur son emprise
car c'est extrêmement accidentogène que
ça pose un énorme problème monsieur le
ministre quand le gouvernement compte se
saisir de ce sujet
pour vous répondre la parole est à mes
chevilles de la santé de la prévention
monsieur Brown Président Mesdames et
Messieurs et sénateurs madame la
sénatrice l'état je vous rejoins le MES
usages du protoxyde d'azote et un
problème de santé publique qui touche
principalement les plus jeunes puisque
plus de 5% des enfants au collège en 3e
déclare avoir déjà utilisé ce protoxyde
d'azote à des fins récréatives alors il
y a deux axes un axe prévention un axe
sanction comme le test que vous avez
porté concernant la prévention tout
d'abord la connaissance du produit vous
le dit très bien on améliore nos
connaissances sur ce produit sur sa
toxicité c'est un produit qui est connu
depuis longtemps qui est utilisé en
fonction de son pourcentage par rapport
à l'oxygène soit comme un gaz
anesthésique soit comme un gaz
antalgique soi-même comme un gaz
hilarant ces nouvelles toxicités que
l'on découvre elle touche effectivement
le système nerveux central mais il faut
pas oublier une toxicité immédiate en
cas d'asphyxie qui est particulièrement
dangereuse l'information est de lance
nous remontons les informations au
niveau national maintenant région par
région ça nous a permis en particulier
dans votre région d'avoir une campagne
d'information très ciblée envers les
jeunes entre 15 et 25 ans en utilisant
les réseaux sociaux et nous allons
continuer dans cette voie en ce qui
concerne la loi que vous avez portée
l'année dernière plusieurs applications
de cette loi sont déjà en cours que cela
concerne l'interdiction devant au mineur
l'interdiction de vendre dans les débits
de boissons l'interdiction de vendre des
crackers qui sont ces
dispositifs qui permettent justement ce
MES usages tout comme la création d'un
délit pour des personnes majeures qui
pousseraient des jeunes à l'utiliser en
ce qui concerne la suite de votre projet
de loi comme vous le savez cela était
notifié à la Commission européenne en
février dernier la commission et le
ministère ont fait plusieurs
allers-retours un décret un arrêté sont
en cours de publication j'espère avant
la fin du mois de février le décret
concerne les informations sur les boîtes
et sur les produits et l'arrêter
concerne la limitation de vente de 10
capsules maximum par personne nous
sommes mobilisés face à ce problème de
santé publique nous accélérons avec la
Commission européenne pour pouvoir
publier ces textes au plus vite
merci la parole est de notre collègue
Pierre Cuypers pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je voudrais associer à cette
question la sénatrice Christina Pluchet
jeudi 19 janvier jour funeste pour
l'agriculture française la Cour de
justice européenne décide de rendre
illégal les dérogations prévues pour la
filière betteravière sur l'utilisation
des néonicotinoïdes le 30 octobre 2020
votre prédécesseur affirmé avec justesse
que la situation était perduement grave
et que tout devait être mis en oeuvre
pour protéger cette filière de même le
président de la République affirmait
haut et fort qu'il ne devait pas y avoir
d'interdit sans solution vous-même
monsieur le ministre vous m'affirmiez le
12 janvier être certain de la
reconduction de dérogations prévues pour
de plus en 2016 la France a interdit
l'usage de tous les néo nécotinoïdes en
aspersion ou en enrobage de semences ce
que l'Allemagne et tous les autres pays
s'autorisent la France s'est mise dans
l'impasse en 2020 la catastrophe de la
jeunesse de la betterave avait
occasionné 200 millions de pertes malgré
les engagements pris l'indemnisation n'a
été que de 10 à 30% du préjudice notre
souveraineté alimentaire est énergétique
et donc menacée quelle réponse concrète
le gouvernement entend apporter à cette
situation et à cette crise latente
monsieur le ministre il vous reste moins
de 10 jours pour apporter toutes les
solutions qui s'imposent car les
agriculteurs doivent prévoir leur semi
[Applaudissements]
la recherche de solutions alternatives
soit dans celle qui était dans le plan
national de recherche je rappelle qu'on
avait mis plus de 20 millions d'euros
entre les acteurs de la filière et
l'État au travers de recherche que
melinra et qu'on travaille avec ma
collègue Retailleau et puis deuxième
élément d'essayer de travailler sur
d'autres recherches et d'autres
itinérateurs techniques avec des
molécules qui sont encore autorisées
j'ai demandé à ce qu'on expertise très
vite pour regarder les solutions pour le
coup en foliaire qui pourrait être
expertisé troisième élément vous avez
raison monsieur sénateur je maintiens ce
que a dit mon prédécesseur ce qui a dit
le président de la République et ce que
j'ai dit pas l'interdiction sans
solution la vérité c'est que cette
interdiction elle procède de 2016 le
principe de précaution à la charge de
l'environnement et d'être là de bien
avant donc c'est il faut qu'on assume
aussi les décisions qui ont été prises
c'est difficile pour tout le monde y
compris pour le ministre de
l'Agriculture c'est difficile surtout
pour les betteraviers moi mon sujet
c'est de leur donner de la visibilité la
visibilité c'est le plan de soutien sur
la jaunisse et c'est d'associer aussi
les transformateurs pour faire en sorte
que ils bénéficient des betteraves dont
ils ont besoin pour faire tourner les
outils de production nous allons y
travailler dans les jours qui viennent
nous nous sommes déjà à l'oeuvre
je récupère
je connaissais votre réponse mais il
faut des solutions et des certitudes
parce qu'au-delà de la compréhension
au-delà de l'impuissance française c'est
la colère c'est le désarroi c'est le feu
dans nos territoires c'est le saccage
annoncé de nos filières c'est la mise en
péril de l'industrie de sucre de
l'alcool du bioéthanol du gel
hydroalcoolique de l'alimentation
animale c'est le risque d'importation
massive de sucre ou d'éthanol notamment
du Brésil qui est produit avec des
produits que nous refusons ici en France
cet obéir c'est opéré la souveraineté
alimentaire et énergétique la France
devient le seul pays au monde à tous ces
interdits
la parole est à notre collègue
Usain bourvu pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
messieurs le gouvernement mesdames
Messieurs chers collègues ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Intérieur
cela fait 4 mois que l'Iran connaît un
mouvement citoyen inédit afin de
dénoncer le régime théocratique ces
violations des droits fondamentaux et
des libertés publiques comme vous le
savez ce mouvement est né au lendemain
de la mort de
Massa mini accusé de ne pas avoir porté
correctement son voile
depuis ce sont surtout des femmes et des
hommes qui sont à la pointe de cette
mobilisation
en retour la répression du régime est
implacable des milliers d'arrestations
500 morts des simulacres de procès des
exécutions sommaires
persécutés par le régime iranien des
opposants fuient l'Iran et trouvent
refuge pour certains en France c'est le
cas de Farid une Iranienne de 38 ans
interpellé la semaine dernière par la
police aux frontières à l'aéroport de
Chambéry alors qu'elle souhaitait se
rendre en Angleterre pour rejoindre son
mari réfugié là-bas elle fut ensuite
transférée au centre de rétention
administrative de Toulouse enfermé
pendant 48 heures avant d'être libéré
pendant que la préfecture prenait une
obligation de quitter le territoire
français et contacter les services
consulaires iraniens en France afin
d'envisager sa reconduite à la frontière
comme c'est le cas et comme c'est
l'usage à chaque fois qu'une obligation
de quitter le territoire est prise
cela nous interpelle cela nous interroge
parce que la France à l'instar des
autres pays occidentaux par la voie du
président de la République de plusieurs
ministres ici présents a condamné à la
répression en œuvre en Iran et apporter
son soutien aux manifestants monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur pouvez-vous nous
préciser la doctrine de la France à
l'égard des opposants au régime iranien
présent notre pays qu'ils soient en
situation régulière ou irrégulière pour
vous répondre la parole est à Monsieur
mis l'intérieur des Outre-mer monsieur
Darmanin
après ce premier contrôle trois autres
contrôles ont été constatés par la
police aux frontières la République ne
peut pas accepter quelqu'un qui est
irrégulièrement sur le territoire
national cette personne ne veut pas
rester en France elle ne veut pas
demander l'asile en France elle ne veut
pas de titre de séjour en France nous
l'aurions accueilli évidemment mais elle
veut rejoindre que vous l'avez dit sa
famille qui est en Angleterre il ne
s'agit donc pas pour la France de
ramener vers l'Iran des ressortissants
nous ne ramenons plus évidemment vers
l'Iran des ressortissants nous
identifions les personnes s'ils ne
veulent pas rester sur notre sol on va
pas leur donner des papiers de force
avouer bien volontiers les choses et
nous avons contacté le Royaume-Uni pour
qu'elle puisse se rapprocher de sa
famille nous avons encore reçu réponse
de la part du gouvernement britannique
mais je veux ici vous assurer que des
excuseront personne et encore moins la
personne que vous évoquez en Iran ne
leur réinvitons et si vous avez contact
avec elle je vous demande de le faire si
elle le souhaite de déposer un dossier
de mandatile en France de l'étudierons
évidemment avec rapidité et avec
humanité
ce Bourget
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie
pour la réponse mais comme vous le savez
son mari est en Angleterre c'est là-bas
qu'elle compte faire ses démarches je
voulais vous dire Monsieur le Ministre
que l'histoire de notre pays elle est
grande elle est belle elle nous donne
chaque jour à chacun à chacune d'entre
nous des motifs légitimes d'en tirer une
fierté particulière parfois elle connaît
des zones d'ombre cette histoire de
France lorsque nous n'avons pas su ou
pas voulu apporter la protection
nécessaire à ceux qui travaillent pour
l'armée française en Afghanistan les
fixeurs les grids les traducteurs je
vous demande monsieur le ministre et je
m'adresse à vous en tant que ministre
mais je m'adresse surtout à votre
conscience avezi à ce que les 50
Iraniens qui sont aujourd'hui sous le
coup de nos qtf ne soit pas renvoyé dans
leur pays quand vous connaissez très
bien le sort qui pourrait leur être
réservé je parle de cette dame mais je
parle iranien
la parole est à notre collègue Olivier
Pacaud pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'éducation
nationale monsieur le ministre dans le
calendrier révolutionnaire nous sommes
en pluvios c'est le mois de la pluie et
il pleut des annonces de fermeture de
classe partout dans le pays surtout en
zone rurale alors avec 59 milliards de
budget 6 et demi pour cent de haut on ne
peut que déplorer ces coupes sombres
2000 postes en moins certes la
démographie scolaire connaît une baisse
continue certes cette revalorisation
enfin ce budget conséquent permettra une
revalorisation indispensable des
rémunérations des enseignants mais alors
que tous les classements internationaux
toutes les évaluations nationales alerte
sur la fragilisation de du niveau global
des élèves alors que vous vantez les
vertus des effectifs réduits où est la
cohérence pédagogique et surtout où est
la justice territoriale quand à quelques
kilomètres quelques hectomètres parfois
ici on va fermer une classe parce
qu'avec 22 gamins ils sont trop nombreux
et à côté on va se réjouir d'avoir 12
gamins dans une classe dédoublée pour
plus d'efficacité je le rappelle 70% des
élèves qui relèvent de l'éducation
prioritaire se trouve en zone rurale ou
dans des quartiers qui ne sont pas
concernés
monsieur le ministre ma question elle
est simple la ruralité est-elle devenue
la variable d'ajustement de vos
politiques éducatives
pour vous répondre
la parole est communiste de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Paco vous l'avez dit la
démographie scolaire connaît une baisse
importante depuis plusieurs années une
baisse qui va à s'accentuer au rythme de
90 000 à 100 000 élèves de moins chaque
année nous prévoyons une baisse donc de
d'environ 500 000 élèves d'ici à la fin
du quinquennat dans votre département de
l'Oise par exemple ce sont
1367 élèves que l'on va compter en moins
à la prochaine rentrée dans ce contexte
de baisse démographique le taux
d'encadrement c'est à dire le ratio
entre professeurs et élèves s'améliorent
depuis plusieurs années il va continuer
à s'améliorer par exemple dans l'Oise il
y a en moyenne
21,5% 21,5 élèves par classe et cette
moyenne va s'améliorer légèrement
l'année prochaine nous avons créé ces
dernières années sans deux postes de
professeur dans l'Oise pour une baisse
de
6631 élèves dans le budget 2023 nous
avons comme vous l'avez dit donner la
priorité à la revalorisation des
professeurs parce que monsieur le
sénateur à quoi sert-il de créer des
postes si nous ne pouvons pas pourvoir
les postes la question est donc d'abord
de pourvoir les postes que nous créons
avant de les multiplier sans que cela
est un effet sur le terrain quant aux
fermetures que vous évoquez nous ne le
faisons pas de manière arithmétique bien
au contraire dans chaque département les
dazaines sont au début du processus de
préparation de la rentrée 2023 avec les
élus locaux il travaille pour
identifier les situations sensibles et
je suis particulièrement sensible
moi-même à la situation des zones
rurales et des écoles rurales
de manière à faire des ajustements en
juin et également en août à la fin août
à ce stade rien n'est définitivement
arrêté et je serai heureux d'en reparler
avec vous
monsieur Paco oui merci d'avoir juste à
la fin
évoquer la ruralité parce que un des
gros problèmes de l'éducation nationale
mais même des politiques publiques
depuis des années c'est l'oubli de ces
territoires en 1947 Jean-François
gravier publié Paris et le désert
français depuis 2017 Emmanuel Macron
décline les métropoles et le désert
français la France c'est sans un
département 35000 communes 68 millions
d'habitants et la République c'est aussi
et surtout l'égalité des droits et des
chances partout et pour tous
merci
la parole est
à notre collègue Laurent Duplomb pour le
groupe les républicain
[Applaudissements]
je m'adresse à tous les ministres tant
le sujet nous concerne tous
savez-vous que la présidente de la
Commission européenne a autorisé le 3
janvier dernier un nouvel aliment
savez-vous que ce nouvel aliment est une
farine partiellement dégraissée
incorporez dans de multiples recettes
savez-vous que depuis hier vous pouvez
trouver cette farine sans informations
claire du consommateur dans les pins
biscuits sauce plat transformée pizza
confiserie ou pâtes et j'en passe et des
meilleurs enfin savez-vous que cette
farine partiellement dégraissée est
faite avec des acheteurs domesticus
entiers broyés en poudre alors madame et
messieurs mesdames et messieurs les
ministres savez-vous ce qu'est
l'acheteur domesticus
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre d'agriculture de la
souveraineté alimentaire monsieur féno
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs oui monsieur le
sénateur je crois que c'est un insecte
et donc c'est bien la question vous
voulez poser c'est de savoir d'abord
pour dire que pardon de vous le dire il
n'est pas nouveau y compris depuis très
longtemps que dans un certain nombre de
pays on puisse se nourrir d'insectes ce
n'est pas en soi on peut avoir des goûts
différents moi compris mais c'est une
réalité deuxième élément ça participe
tout à fait d'une réglementation
européenne qui a été autorisée
simplement la réglementation européenne
exige monsieur le sénateur c'est qu'on
mentionne la nature du produit en
l'occurrence pour ce cet insecte la
question de l'allergénéité des uns et
des autres donc il faut qu'on soit
vigilant sur la mention dans les
produits qui seront dedans disant qu'il
y a un produit qui peut être allergène
en l'occurrence cet insecte troisième
élément au travail au niveau européen
globalement essayer d'harmoniser les
choses et c'est mieux que ça soit au
niveau européen que chaque pays décide
de commercialiser telle ou tel autre et
donc c'est ça sur lequel on a besoin de
travailler ça nécessite aussi et nous
avons besoin de continuer à renforcer à
nos frontières européennes mais aussi au
niveau national la surveillance
sanitaire parce qu'il y a toujours des
gens qui essayent de déroger aux règles
que nous nous fixions au niveau européen
ça existe dans le sujet agricole et
sanitaire comme d'un bien d'autres
sujets donc il faut qu'on y travaille
qu'on continue à avancer mais
reconnaissons que les mesures qui sont
prises elles vivent plutôt à protéger à
informer le consommateur à protéger le
cas échéant l'environnement et donc
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut qu'on
travaille sans travailler sur des
questions distorsion de concurrence ça
me permet un dernier mot monsieur le
sénateur il me semble que sur ces sujets
il faut qu'on travaille justement au
niveau européen rien ne s'épuise on en a
parlé dans un autre exemple tout à
l'heure que d'avoir des dispositions qui
s'appliquent simplement sur le sol
français qui ne s'applique pas au niveau
européen donc la bataille elle est
d'abord européenne et c'est là-dessus
qu'il faut qu'on continue à travailler
monsieur Duplomb
monsieur le ministre comment en
sommes-nous arrivés là à devoir
consommer des grillons de la même
famille que les sauterelles ou les
criquets alors que la France est le pays
de la gastronomie et des terroirs
comment pouvez-vous laisser faire cela
alors que vous n'avez de cesse de nous
parler d'une alimentation saine et
durable d'agroécologie et de circuits
courts saine et durable cette farine ne
l'est pas même la Commission ne garantit
pas l'absence de problèmes sanitaires
contrairement à ce que vous venez de
dire où est l'agroécologie avec
l'élevage hors sol de millions de
grillons dans des bâtiments industriels
et que dire des circuits courts alors
que cette poudre de Grillon est importée
du Vietnam cette Commission européenne
qui cède au lobby antiviande et qui sape
notre agriculture et notre culture
gastronomique je n'en veux plus
soutenant plutôt la farine de blé plutôt
que la farine de Grillon soutenant le
sucre français plutôt que les insectes
d'Asie nous ne pouvons pas accepter de
faire manger à leur insu des insectes
aux Français ceux qui souhaitent manger
des grillons sur le ministre je les
invite à venir les manger directement
dans mes prés ils seront nature entier
non broyés et non transformés et pour
tous les autres je leur conseille de
constituer que de continuer à manger une
bonne côte de bœuf
[Applaudissements]
mes chers collègues
après chers recommandation gastronomique
je vous rappelle là c'est une annonce
particulièrement importante que mercredi
1er février à 14h30 nous recevrons
monsieur rousselink président de la Rada
d'Ukraine dans notre émission et qui
s'exprimera je compte particulièrement
sur la présence de chacune et de chacun
l'accord avec le gouvernement les
questions d'actualité débuteront donc à
titre exceptionnel avec 15 minutes de
décalage donc à 15h15
je vais maintenant suspendre la séance
ce sera reprise à 16h30 pour l'examen de
trois conventions internationales puis
pour la suite de l'examen du projet de
loi relatif aux Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 la séance est
suspendue